النجم جورج خباز يطل على الجمهور بدور نار
في النار بالنار هو تالق قليله في وصف
اللي بيعملوا احمد فهيم في دور سيد العمده
ولسان حال كل الناس كنت فين يا راجل اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
انت جايه هيك من شركه لسانك طويل يعني ولا
مركبه ابليكيشن كل ما وعدلي الادب لازم
يكون متحف حبيبي مش ملجا للناجحين خطف سته
سبعه وثمانين
لما خلصت
المسلسل
بين الناس والحوارات اللي بتصير بين مريم
وبين جورج خباز وعزيز وصورهم صارت جزء
اساسي من البوستات والتغريدات الجدليه
اللي بنشوفها يوميا وبعد كل حلقه على
المنصه
اما الارشادات بدون جورج فماليه من السطوع
وعنوانها ابداع واتقان
ومعنى النجم جوج خباز اهلا فيك معنا جورج
والف مبروك نجاح العمل هذا النجاح الكبير
يعني
مساء الخير
استاذي ساره وشكرا كتير شكرا طب احنا
خلينا نبتدي نتكلم من الدور يعني احنا
عرضنا التغريدات الناس كلها بتتكلم في
التغريدات هذه بتقول انك انت لابس الدور
لبس الدور ما هو يعني الدور انت بتبين
فيها هادي بس نحن بنحس طول الوقت انه في
غليان جالس جنب جوا بصير جوا هذا الشخص
كيف الواحد كيف بتحسستنا بهذا الشعور بدون
ما بتكون جالس بتصرخ وبتجري زي المجنون
يعني
مدام ساره انا اللي بيغريني باي دور
تمثيلي اني العبوا هو صراعه الداخلي وهيدي
الشخصيه عندها صراع داخلي صراع ما بين
انسينيته وما بين شروط حياته هو مرهف
الاحساس هو بيانييست عازف بيانو وبنفس
الوقت عنده تاريخ حزين هذا التاريخ الحزين
مخليه يصير انطوائي وعنصري وهذا الشيء
انعكس على سلوكه فهذا التناقض ما بين
رواقه كموسيقي وما بين غضبه المشحون عبر
السنين خليني اعمل الشخصيه بهذه الطريقه
طيب بس اليوم لما من اول ما بدا عرض
المسلسل الناس كلها كانت بتقول هذا مسلسل
جريء جريء جريء انصدمنا من حجم الشفافيه
والجراه في الحوار وفي وصف يعني خلينا
نقول اللي هي بتكون زي المناوشات اللي
بتصير بين اللبنانيين والسوريين وحسسنا
انها يعني فعلا واقعيه يعني اللي بيصير في
المشاهد لما قرات السكريبت ما حسيت انه
اوف هذا الكلام جريء ما عمرنا عملنا شيء
قبل كده زي كده
هو صراحه خليني بس صحح التسميه هو صريح
اكثر منه جريء لانه هذا الواقع هو بفرجي
هالمسلسل نماذج من المجتمع وكل نموذج عم
بيقول رايه وطريقته من وجهه نظره بلغه
الناس بلغه الشارع وهيدي حلاوه هذا
المسلسل يعني حان الوقت انه اذا بدنا
نعالج موضوع له بعد انسانه مثل النار
بالنار مثل موضوع النار بالنار موضوع
العنصريه وخلاف شعبين عايشين مع بعضهم
لازم نحكي الامور مثل ما بتنحكى لنقدر
نوصل للنتيجه هلا انا ما بقدر اجاوبك جواب
كامل لانه نكون عم يجتزيئ رساله المسلسل
خلينا ننطر احداث المسلسل وين بتصير وين
بتصير شخصيه عزيز لاقدر احكيك اكثر واكثر
بهدا الموضوع لما نحرق عناصر المفاجاه
اللي وبنفس الوقت متل ما قلت لك العبره
الانسانيه يلي جايه من هالمسلسل لانه انتم
حتى الان يعني صار في كثير جدل على يعني
على الحوارات على الاشياء وصاروا الناس
بيقولوا انه هدول بحاولوا العنصريه
والنعرات وما الى ذلك ولكن انت تحديدا لما
انتشر مشهد بينك وبين كريس بشار وصارت في
مواجهه حاميه نزلت بوست كان مهم خلينا لو
بس نعرضه على الشاشه
حطيت هذا البوست لك انت وكريس وهذه لقطه
ما ظهرت من المسلسل اللي كنت بتقول للناس
انه استنوا وشكلكم انه كفوا المسلسل على
قولتك يعني كملوا واستنوا وهنا شكلكم يعني
كانكم اصحاب وكانها بتدلعك يا جورج
هلا انا وكريس كتير كتير اصحاب بالكواليس
حقيقه انا كسبت صديقه وكسبت مش بس يعني
قيمه فنيه قيمه انسانيه بكل ما بالكلمه من
معنا انا اول مره بمثل مع
كريسبي مشاهد اكثريتهم معها فانا سعيد جدا
بهذه الثنائيه اذا بدك لانه حياتك كاريس
بشار محترفه ممثله من العيار الثقيل دمها
خفيف جدا
متمسكه لعملها شغوفه جدا واحد بيتفرج
عليها وبينعدى منها شغف فانا سعيد جدا
بهذا المكسب وهذه الصداقه وطبعا استاذ عبد
فهد كمان نفس الشيء بس مشاهد قليله معه مع
انه كمان صار في صداقه بيني وبينه كتير
كبيره بالكواليس اكيد عم نفرجي اول شيء
صدقتنا على صعيد شخصي وعم نكب شويه اذا
بدك عم ينكب شويه التساؤلات انه ماذا
سيحصل بين هالشخصين اللي عم يتنافسوا كل
الوقت ويتخانقوا كل الوقت صح لانه الاحداث
ماشيه في معين بس نحن حاسين انه ما بدي
احرق على الناس يمكن حتمشي في اتجاه تاني
المهم حنشوف بس انا بقول للناس يتفرجوا
على المسلسل لانه فعلا يعني عمل صراحه
معمول باتقان يعني بس بما انك يعني ذكرت
حتى ما نزيد الجدل جدل يعني بما انه كمان
ذكرت يعني اسماء يعني الابطال زملائك معك
في العمل خليني اول شيء ابتدي من عند
كاريز كنيس انت بتمدح فيها الان كثير هي
كريس قالت قبل ما تبتدي تمثل معاك انها
اول مره حتمثل معك وانها متخوفه جدا من
هذا الموضوع لانه هي شايفه انك انت يعني
جدا فنان ثقيل فكانت خايفه هل عبرت لك عن
هذه المشاعر
اول شيء انا ما معي خبر اللي عم بتقوليه
ابدا صراحه اول مره بسمعوا منك ما بعتقد
ابدا حقيقه حقيقه اكثر حدا رحب بوجودي
بهالمسلسل هو استاذ عبد فهد واكثر حدا كان
عم يساعدني وعم يعطيني يعني في تناغم بيني
وبينه هو استاذ عبد فهد وحقيقه كل ما عامل
مشهد حلو عم بتلفن لي ويهنيني او يبعث لي
مسج ويقول لي انه هو فخور بشغله من اول ما
بلشت مسلسل انت هذه اللحظه فما بعتقد انه
هيدي شغله يعني اول شيء ما بعرف شي عنها
بس ما بعتقد شغله بتخصنا لانه انا وياه
نحن بنعتبر حالنا وحاكيين بهذا الموضوع
كونا اثنيناتنا بنلعب كره قدم بنعتبر
حيلنا نحن فريق متماسك متل كره القدم كل
واحد بيعطي للثاني لحتى نحن الهدف يكون
واحد بالاخر هو نجاح هذا المسلسل هو بس
احقاقا للحق المخرج رجع رد كمان تحيه
كبيره كبيره لاستاذ هو كمان بقول لك احقق
الحق المخرج رجع رجع لعابد فهد
وعابد رجع يرد عليه قال له انه لا ابدا
انه الفرق بين المسرح والتلفزيون وما بعرف
شو انه المخرج منتبه للممثلين وما شابه
جورج ممثل من العيار الثقيل ولو فانه يعني
رجع كان عنده رد يبدو انه بحاول يكسر في
الكلام
اللي اتفسر بس هي لانه انا
جورج خلينا نتفق اتفاق لانك انت من الاول
بتقول لي استاذه استنى بتقولي استاذه
بتقول لي مدام دحين بتقول لي سيده الكريمه
عشان انا بقول لك جورج ولا اقول لك لازم
استاذ جورج كمان اوكي ساره اوكي
ساره بس تخبرك انه انا مش كثير بتابع يعني
مني كتير انتم سوشيال ميديا ما بتابع يعني
جديد بالنسبه لالي بس كل اللي بقدر اقول
لك هو اذا بدك نوقف هذه الجلاليه انا
واستاذ عابد فهد على صداقه وحكيت عنه
وحكيت معه عنه ببرنامج صدى الملاعب من كل
قلبي هو على طول وين ما كان بيحكي عني
منيح نحن اصدقاء وزملاء وانا افتخر اني
وقفت امام هذا العملاق في هذا المسلسل لا
هو صراحه انتم الثلاثه في هذا المسلسل
يعني مباراه خلينا نقول من الاداء بس على
سيره بتقول انك انت ما كثير داخل في عالم
السوشيال ميديا انت ما عندك واتساب كمان
يا جورج كيف عايش كيف معي هعيش معنا على
هذا الكوكب
مضبوط والله عايش عايش عم بتنفس عادي
وسعيد اكيد مروق اكيد اسعد منا من ناحيه
انك انت مروق
والله انا عايش يعني انا عايش مع الطبيعه
بحب الطبيعه كتير بحب البحر بحب الشجر
وعايش ببلتي هون بالبترون على الفيسبا
تبعي وعلى البسكليت تبعي فانا جدا سعيد
بالحياه الطبيعيه
رائع يعني انت بتعطينا مثال وبتذكرنا انه
في اسلوب مختلف للحياه السريعه اللي نحن
سرنا فيها والكلام هذا كله طيب خليني كمان
يمكن بس انقلك انه اوكي شفنا نجاح كبير في
النار بالنار شفنا نجاح كبير في براندو
الشرق كمان كندور كوميدي شفنا نجح كبير في
فيلم اصحاب ولا اعز فجاه حسينا انه جورج
خباز للسنين طويله كان بخيل علينا في
الاداء ومعطي نفسه كله للمسرح
ما انت شاعر بالندم انا كنت متمسك للمسرح
لانه المسرح
المسرح خليني اخبرك بس شغله انه المسرح
بياخدك كتير بيستهلكك بيستهلك يعني في
حضور ذهني وعصبي وجسدي وفكري ليلي ما كنت
قادر اعمل مسرح والتلفزيون او مسرح ودراما
مع بعض وكنت اعمل سينما من وقت لوقت مثل
فيلم تحت القصف مثل فيلم غدي
شاركت بكتابه فيلم كفرنحوم لنديل لبكي
وكنت اعمل افلام سينما من وقت لوقت وقتها
بوقف مسرح ولكن ما كنت قادر جسديا اني
اعمل مسرح ودراما مع بعضه لما وقف المسرح
قصرا بسبب الكورونا بسبب الازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي صارت على لبنان وبطلنا
قدر نفتح مسرح لان صار عنا ازمه تسعير
وازمه تسعير وازمه تعبير اذا بدك أنا صار
عندي وقت اني اقدر اشتغل دراما وسينما
وهذا اللي صار قدرت تصور اصحاب ولا اعز
وبراندو الشرق يلي عملوا نجاح كبير وهلا
عم نحصد نجاح النار بالنار ابدا لانه بدي
اقول لك شغله خلاصه شغل اللي عم بتشوفيها
هلا بعتقد سبب النجاح بهذه الادوار هو
تراكم خبراتي بالمسرح وصلتني اني العب
الادوار بهذه الطريقه بعتقد هيك طيب جورج
عندنا الكل جالس بيقول انه بدنا نجري كلنا
نقضي عندك ويكند نقفل فيها تليفوناتنا من
غير واتساب ونقعد معك نجرب الحياه باسلوبك
والله يا اهلا وسهلا فيكم بنروح بنتصيد
سمك نحن واياكم اهلا وسهلا فيكم بتنورونا
كمان جورج انت مدرسه نحتاج نتعلم منها
كثير اشياء خارج حتى الفن انا بشكرك جدا
يا جورج على ظهورك معنا اليوم
وفعلا فعلا فعلا انتم مكسرين الدنيا في
المسلسل وحديث الناس ونكمل متابعه علشان
نشوف تطور الله يخليك شكرا لك كان معنا
النجم جورج شكرا يا ساره ورمضان كريم
علينا وعليك يا رب
الفنان احمد فهيم اللي في تاريخه مجموعه
من الاعمال الدراميه المهمه اللي تالق
فيها وعملت صدى كبير هذه السنه اسمه متصدر
الاخبار والعناوين اللي عنوانها العريض
كنت فيني راجل احمد بيشارك في هذا الموسم
الرمضاني بعملين جعفر العمده وعمله نادره
فهو في مسلسل جعفر العمده بياخد دور سيد
اخو جعفر العمده ومن اول ما بدا المسلسل
اللي مكسر الدنيا وعامل ضجه كبيره ومتصدر
قائمه اكثر الاعمال مشاهده والناس بتقول
لاحمد فهيم كنت فين ايش الابداع وايش
التالق فيه الدور اللي متقمصه بكل شيء
سواء حركات مشاعر احاسيس اداء لغه جسد
يعني دور متكامل في كل شيء
احمد صحيح مكسر الدنيا في الدور ولكن من
حلقتين تماما منكسر الدنيا اكثر في مشاهد
خطفت قلوب الناس ومتابعي المسلسل وهو
المشهد اللي شاف فيه سيد مراته داد وهي
بتتزوج من شوقي فتح الله من بعد ما كانت
هربت من البيت الناس شافوا في الحركات
والتعابير اللي عملها احمد في المشهد
اتقان لا يمكن وصفه والناس شافت في احمد
فهيم فنان مبدعه ومتقمص الدور وعايشه بكل
تفاصيل والحركه وحركاته والكل كان بيشيد
باداءه وانه هذا الدور ما كان احد راح
يقدر يعمله بهذا التالق غير هو
ومعنا من القاهره النجم احمد فهيم اهلا
فيك معنا يا احمد وانا طبعا يعني ببارك لك
على هذا النجاح الكبير ويعني شخصيه سيد في
جعفر العمده جننت الناس خصوصا في الاحداث
الاخيره اللي صارت خصوصا بعد ما وداد راحت
تزوجت يعني حالها زوجها او تزوجت واحد
تاني يعني بس قبل ما نبدا يا احمد بدي
اوريك عينه من ردود فعل الناس
بالسلاح جايين انتم اللي خايفين احنا مش
هنغير
[موسيقى]
بسلاح جايين انتوا اللي خايفين احنا مش
هنحل هنخيط اي
[موسيقى]
يلا بينا هو بدا العار
عشان تقعدوا اجيب اخواتي ولا اجيب احمد
مكاوي ولا اجيب مين بالظبط في الشارع
والله انا معاك يا سيد بس يلا قوم
يا سيد الله يكسبك
بالسلاح جايين
انتوا ليه خايفين احنا مش هنهي هنخيط
مش شايف عنتيل
ماشي
[موسيقى]
في الارض مش شايفين
كسبك لوحدك احنا رايحين ناخد حق سيد عمر
ما تيجي الرجاله كلها في الميدان واقف هنا
يا جدعان
احمد ايش رايك في ردود الفعل هذه
والله والله كل سنه وحضراتكم طيبين
وقناه العربيه طيبه ومشاهدين قناه العربيه
في الوطن العربي طيبين
مبسوط جدا اني مع حضرتك وليا الشرف ومتشكر
جدا
للدعوه الكريمه دي والله مبسوط جدا باللي
بيحصل ده يعني
وانبساطي جاي من ان الناس فرحانه يعني
الناس متفاعله مع الحدث الناس حاسه ان هم
ممكن يروحوا يدافعوا عني ممكن ياخدولي حقي
يعني الناس الناس عايشه الحكايه معنا مع
الاحداث ومع المسلسل وهو ده الهدف من من
الحكايه اصلا ومن الشغل ان احنا نحس ان
الجمهور متوحد مع شخصياتنا وقدرنا يعني
يعني يا رب نكون صادقين وقدرنا ونقدر نكون
وصلنا للجمهور المشاعرنا الحقيقيه اللي
كانت جوه الشغل يعني
اداءك في هذا المشهد الكل تكلم على هذا
الموضوع انه اداءك انت تحديدا كانك واحد
جمعت خبرات السنين عشان تطلع بدال مشهد
الحمد لله
الفضل يرجع الاول الحمد لله بشكر ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى على
المنحه للديها لي في الشغل ان انا اعمل
المشهد بالشكل ده وبشكر بعد ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى الفضل يرجع للاستاذ محمد سامي طبعا
الفضل يرجع له بعد ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
وبتوجيهاته بنصايحه وبارشاده ليا ان
المشهد يطلع بالشكل ده الحمد لله
المشهد انا كنت صادق فيه قوي مع نفسي وكنت
عايز اوصل مشاعر والحمد لله يا رب تكون
وصلت للجمهور حطيت نفسي فعلا مكان سيد لو
فعلا مراته عملت كده هيبقى رد فعلي ايه
فاللي طلع ده مش مش ما كانش مترتب ولا كان
ولا كان يعني ما كانش بالورقه والقلم يعني
هو طلع كده لوحده همم نظرته ليها من من
الشباك ومن البلكونه ونزوله الشارع
واخرجوا من الباب بلهفه هو مش فاهم حاجه
هو مش مش هو في اللحظه دي كان في عالم
ثاني غير العالم حتى مشيته لما راح لها
لحد ما راح عند الكوشه ماشي حركه ايديه
الحمد لله الحاجات دي كلها ما كانتش
مترتبه دي بتبقى منحه ربانيه كده الحمد
لله ان هي بشكر ربنا سبحانه وتعالى وبشكر
الاستاذ محمد سامي انه اتاح لي الفرصه
وبشكر زمايلي كلهم اللي كانوا على قدر من
المسؤوليه وان هم وقفوا جنبي ان انا اعمل
مشهد بالشكل ده
ويا رب النتيجه تكون على قد المجهود ونكون
قدرنا نوصل للجمهور شغل كويس يبسطهم في
شهر رمضان
الناس لا مبسوطه ومتفاعله بس انا سمعت
كمان انك انت بتنزل بتتفرج في القهاوي وفي
الشوارع على الناس وهم بيتفرجوا على
المسلسل صحيح
والله مش بشكل
كبير يعني انا في يوم من الايام رحت فطرت
في مكان
قدامه قهوه القهوه بيبقى ناس بعد الفطار
قاعدين على القهوه بشربوا شاي بيشربوا
قهوه بيلعبوا طاوله
وبعد الفطار وقفت
وقفت في البلكونه علشان اشوف رد الفعل
والحمد لله يعني مش قادر اقول لحضرتك اكن
مثلا نهائي كاس العالم الناس مبسوطه جدا
الناس متفاعله الناس بتشجع كان في مشهد هو
اللي هو كان مشهد
الخناقه فالناس مبسوطه جدا متفاعله معنا
فكنت عايز اشوف رد فعل الشارع لان ده ما
حصلش في البرنس للاسف لان كان في كورونا
ما كانش الناس بتنزل على القهاوي فكنت
حابب اشوف ده جدا في جعفر العمده والحمد
لله يا رب نكون يا رب تعبنا جدا ويا رب
يكون النتيجه على قد مجهود اللي احنا
عملناه
يعني اوصف لي مشاعرك الان تجاه وداد مدى
كرهك لوداد قد ما نحن بنكره وداد
انتم بتقراوا جداد انا نسيتها خلاص يعني
انا انا بحاول بحاول اتعافى من سيد لان
سيد كان عامل لي مشكله سيد كان عايش معي
ثلاث شهور اللي هو وقت التصوير كنت انا
وسيد بس عايشين في بيت لوحدنا انا ما شفتش
اولادي ما شفتش اصدقائي ما خرجتش من البيت
كنت بخرج بس اجيب اكل اجيب حاجه وارجع
تاني عايش في البيت انا وسيد ببص في
المرايه بلاقي سيد بكلم سيد بذاكر وانا
سيد طول الوقت انا مركز كل التركيز ويا رب
الحمد لله يعني النتيجه الحمد لله يعني
طلعت الحمد لله على قد المجهود فبحاول
اتعافى منه
بس انا لما انت لما انعرض عليك الدور احمد
سامي حسيت انه ممكن ينجح هذا النجاح الدور
انا اي
اي شغل مع الاستاذ محمد سامي انا بتوقع له
النجاح من قبل ما ابدا فيه لان عارف هو
متاكد وكل ثقه في الاستاذ محمد سامي وفي
قدراته الفنيه العاليه مخرج كبير ومخرج
عبقري يعني
فالنجاح مع الاستاذ محمد سامي مرادف يعني
النجاح مرادف محمد سامي على طول فطبعا كنت
متوقع طبعا وده اللي خلاني اركز جدا في
الشغل واركز جدا في الشخصيه اني عارف
محمد سامي عفوا انت لانك احمد وهو محمد في
عاد بدخل الخطوط في بعض تبع محمد سليم
يعني معروف انه هو بينجم الناس معاه بتنجم
حتى اللي هم مش ما بيكونوا مثلا انه مثلا
محمد رمضان كل اللي حوالينه حتى
بينجموا بس انت شخصيا وانت بتقرا كنت
متوقع هذه رده الفعل
كنت متوقع طبعا رده الفعل وكنت عارف ان كل
وكنت عارف المسلسل كله مش شخصيتي بس كل
الشخصيات كانت اركان متكامله
وشخصيات وشخصيات واضحه كلها فكنت متوقع
النجاح طبعا للمسلسل وللشخصيات كلها ولكن
بصراحه يعني ما كنتش متوقع ان الناس هتبقى
يعني نجاح كنت متوقعه بس ما كنتش متوقع ان
الناس هتبقى فرحانه يعني الناس فرحانه
عشان انا كويس الناس فرحانه علشان
باقي زمايلي كويسين ففي حاله سعاده عند
الناس هي دي الحمد لله اللي كملت الصوره
النهائيه وبحمد ربي على النجاح ده بتشعر
انه هذا الدور انصاف لك والمسيرتك
باين من دموعي الحقيقيه وباين من احساس يا
رب يكون بجد واصلكم ولو وصلكم احساسي يبقى
هو ده اللي انا كنت عايز اوصله لان انا
بشتغل كنت حاسس ان الدور ده
عوض ليا بعد صبر كتير يمكن في مشاهد كثير
كنت بعملها وانا بفتكر الايام اللي صعبه
والدنيا والحاجات وخلاص ويلا ووريني بقى
انت جات لك الفرصه هتعملها ازاي
والفضل يرجع للاستاذ محمد سامي بعد ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى انه اتاح لي الفرصه اني
افرد
جناحاتي واعمل اللي انا عايزه في الدور يا
رب اكون قادر قدرت اقدم حاجه تبسط الناس
يعني احنا مدحنا كثير يا احمد خليني اقول
لك شيء جانب انتقاد طيب بس على الجنب كده
يعني بعض الناس بيقولوا انه بالغته في
المسلسل يعني انه ما بيصير هذه الاشياء في
الحقيقه يعني بيروحوا ومراته بتخلعوا وهو
مش عارف انه مراته خلعته سبع شهور ومش
عارفه ايش والكلام ده كله طب كيف بترد على
اللي بيقولوا انه زودتوها وسعتوها شوي
بصي هو الدراما بتسبح بكده الدراما مرايه
الحقيقه الدراما دايما بتسمح بالمبالغه
وبتسمح بالافوار اللي بيقولوا عليها طول
ما انا في حاله نجاح وطول ما المسلسل
والحلقات في حاله تصاعديه المشاهد موافق
على كل حاجه يعني انا طالما نجحت معك وانت
صدقتني انت موافق على كل حاجه فالدراما
بتسمح
بان انا ازود حاجه واعمل حاجه خارج الاطار
الدراما مش محكومه
يعني مش حياتنا او مش الدنيا اللي احنا
عايشينها ومش هنقدر نحددها في مكان
الدراما ملهاش اركان عالم واسع نقدر نروح
هنا ونروح هنا ونجوز ده ونطلق دي من ده
والحمد لله يعني الناس مبسوطه
والاشاده اكتر من النقد يعني الحمد لله
بس سؤال سريع بس احمد في كف انت اديته
لزينه وبعدين في محمد رمضان اداك كف
الكفوف دي كانت حقيقيه
كان فيها جزء كبير من الحقيقه وجزء يعني
كانت على على نصين زي ما بيقولوا
الحرفيه اللي عند الاستاذ محمد سامي
بيخلينا نضرب يعني هو بيعمل لنا مره
واتنين وتلاته بحيث ان الالم يطلع بالظبط
لكنه يعني حقيقي فعلا والحمد لله باين جدا
في المشاهد الناس كلها بتتكلم على الاكشن
بتاع يعني الاقلام كلها حقيقيه جدا مش
الالم بتاعي بس ولا القلم الاستاذ محمد
رمضان قلم كارم لاخته ودلال كان حقيقي جدا
فكل ففي حرفيه عاليه جدا في الاداء بتوضح
قد ايه حتى لو القلم مش حقيقي هو وصل
للمشاهد انه حقيقي وانا عجبتني فكره
التمثيل من ده الموضوع انه ممكن الواحد
يفضل كده يضرب اقلام في الناس وكده طيب
احمد خليك معانا لانه ما ينفع كمان ما
نتكلم عن عملك الثاني اللي انت حتى طالع
لنا اليوم في
الازياء حقت اللي هو عمله نادره واللي انت
طبعا طالع معانا من موقع التصوير وطبعا زي
ما ذكرت مشاهدينا برضه بلبس التصوير في
مسلسل عمله نادره انت احمد فهيم بيلعب دور
عطيه اللي بيتصل بانه عاد عنيد وعصبي
ومتعند برايه وخاصه مع اخوه اللي بيتامر
هو وابنه عليه علشان يقعد مكانه ويصير هو
كبير العيله
ونرجع لك يا احمد انتم اليوم اخر يوم
تصوير في عمرنادره
او شخصيتك يعني
النهارده اخر يوم في تصوير المسلسل كله مش
انا بس النهارده اخر يوم في التصوير مسلسل
العمله نادره انا عملت اخر مشهد يعني
بسرعه جدا علشان اجي الحق الهوا خلصوني
حتى اول واحد معي اه والله معي الاستاذ
كمال ابو رقيه ومعي الاستاذ هشام عاشور
بسرعه خلصوني بسرعه علشان الحق الهواء مع
حضرتك وجبنا بسرعه زرعه كده صغيره من بره
مش عارف جبناها منين وعملوا ايه وعشان
نبان ان احنا يعني كويس احنا في مكان صعب
جدا كمان احنا في الصحراء عاملين بلد في
الصحراء فحاولنا يعني عجباكم الزرعه دي
حلوه تجنن انت اصلا وجودك كله معانا يا
احمد انت اللي تجنن صراحه يعني سيبك من
الزرعه انت حضورك هو اللي مميز بالنسبه
لنا
يعني
عمله نادره اللي يشوف عمله نادره يقول انه
لا ده مش يعني ابدا سيد اخو جعفر يعني
شخصيه مختلفه تماما هل تقاطع التصوير بينه
وبين بعض شويه او لا هذا خلصت منه بعدين
دخلت الشخصيه الثانيه تماما
والله الحمد لله برضو بفضل ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى قدرت كنت بدات جعفر العمده قبل
عمله نادره وخلصت تقريبا 70% من شغلي في
جعفر العمده قبل ما ابدا كنت بدات عمله
نادره بس كنت لسه يعني ما دخلتش في الغويط
زي ما بيقولوا بعمل يعني بروح يوم وتلاته
لا
بعد ما خلصت جعفر العمده شغلي بقى الكثير
بدا في عمله نادره فقدرت ان انا اوفق بين
هنا وبين هنا فكان في شويه حاجات كده يعني
همم تعارض في المواعيد بس الحمد لله اتحلت
وده اللي اداني مساحه شويه اني اقدر اني
اقدر افصل بين الشخصيتين بين سيد وبين
عطيه الحمد لله قدرت اعمل هنا شخصيه وقدرت
اعمل هنا شخصيه بالتوازي مع بعض الاتنين
كانوا مجنني كنت عايش معاهم زي ما قلت
لحضرتك في بيت واحد انا وهم بس ما بشوفش
حد ما بشوفش اولادي ساعات اكلم عطيه سيد
يرد عليا اضرب عطيه سيد يزعل مني يعني كنت
عايش
يعني بس يعني صحتك العقليه بعدين بس
خايفين عليك يا احمد
لسه بقول لحضرتك انا بحاول اتعافى من سيد
يعني انا عطيه لسه معايا بعد ما اخلص مع
حضرتك هرميه دلوقتي وانا ماشي في الصحراء
موضوع الموضوع صعب جدا على الممثل الموضوع
ان هو
يجسد شخصيه ده او اتنين كمان مع بعض
ولو كمان لو عايز يتقنهم قوي ويعيش معهم
موضوع كان صعب جدا واعتقد ان هي مدارس
يعني في مدرسه اللي هي مدرسه الاستاذ احمد
زكي مدرسه
رحمه الله عليه مدرسه الاستاذ خالد صالح
رحمه الله عليه مدرسه ناس كتير من
الاساتذه الافاضل الكبار المدرسه دي انا
بحبها مدرسه التقمص وانا بحب اعيش الشخصيه
واعيش معاها واخرج من ذاتي اروح لسيد
واروح لعطيه وبعدين ارميهم في الشارع بعد
ما اخلص وارجع تاني لحياتي الاجتماعيه ده
بياثر عليا طبعا بس هي دي المتعه في
الشغلانه في الاخر فرحه الجمهور ورضا
الجمهور عني هو اللي بيخلي اي مجهود
يتلاشى يعني طب انت يعني طبعا ذكرت نجمان
يعني كبار جدا يعني الراحل احمد زكي الله
يرحمه وطبع ا الراحل خالد صالح طبعا
يمكن اللي الناس ما تعرفوا انه خالد صالح
هو خالك اخو والدتك
مظبوط يا فندم المرحوم الفنان خالد صالح
خالد ففي ناس كثير لما عرفت هذه المعلومه
بداوا يحطوا الشبه ويحطوا الشبه بزياده
وياخدوا صور ويقارنوا على التعبيرات وكده
خلينا الان شايفينها نحن على الشاشه يعني
لما بتحط الصور بدي الطريقه بيتضح الشبه
بشكل كبير جدا ايش تاثرت فيه يا احمد
بصي انا اتعلمت اصلا الحكايه من خلال
المرحوم خالد صالح حبيت الموضوع من خلال
مرحوم خالد صالح اتعلمت الحكايه كلها من
اولها لاخرها
هو كان قدوتي في الشغلانه وفي الحياه
عموما يعني التصرفاتي
علاقتي بالناس علاقتي بالاخرين
اتعلمت منه المهنه طول الوقت كان بيرشدني
وكان بينصحني مابخلش علي باي معلومه ماشي
بنصايحه لحد دلوقتي كان دايما يقول لي ما
تعملش حاجه انت مش قدها ما تعملش لقاء
صحفي وانت لقاء تلفزيوني وانت لسه ما حدش
يعرفك ما تقبلش دور كبير وانت لسه مش قده
ويمكن ده اللي اخرني شويه بس الحمد لله
يعني كانت نصائح مهمه جدا
اخيرا بقى يعني لو في حاجه حلوه تبقى من
المرحوم خالي الفنان خالد صالح رحمه الله
عليه الله يرحمه وطبعا العمر لك ان شاء
الله والمزيد من النجاح والنجوميه يا احمد
احنا بنشكرك على وجودك معنا اليوم منور
منور منور هذا رمضان يعني فعلا
رائع كان هذا المسلسلين صراحه العملين
شكرا لك كان معنا من القاهره النجم احمد
شاهين شكرا لك
مشاهدينا في امان الله
[موسيقى]